We're not quite done however, so far we've been in the,
we've been engaged in building the state chart model. Once the modeling is over,
the resulting stays sharp but still be validated.
There are various ways we could, we could perform this check.
We could hold a review that is get a team of people involved in.
I'll walk through the use cases and make sure that each of the concurrent
machines is doing what you would expect it to do. You could do model checking.
Model checking is a, is an automated technique where you can
encode all of the concurrent state machines and any
questions or tests. You'd like to determine whether or
not the state machine can ever happen in the state machines and then you can run
what's called a model checker to determine whether those things can ever happen.
And we could even and this is similar to but he could have a separate,
we could build a simulator of the execution using some kind of
state chart interpreter, which probably others as, as well, including going
back to the users with any questions that arise during this validation process.